Are you struggling with
your relationship with God?
Do you feel like He's not
listening to your prayers?
Well maybe, it's because you're not fully
committed to Him and because you're not
putting Him first in your life.
In my new book, Bold Pursuit,
let me just read a quote for you here.
I said God is always waiting.
The God of the universe is
always there waiting for us.
God is more eager to reveal Himself
to us than we are to seek Him.
It's time we turn back to God fully.
It's time we fall on our knees
and it's time we return to the Bible.
Do you live your life according to the Bible?
Or do you want to change the Bible
to just fit in with your lifestyle?
If you say you're a true Christian, then you need
to live the way God wants you to live. And put him
first in everything.
I love you guys.
See in the next video.
Bye.